[Musica]
dj mai hagar ii papi j paj arrivò mai a
gara a chi fa cagare
successo invece che è uscito un magari
non persone di offida
vabbè facciamolo bella tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti a questo video sono fa vj
merci siamo sud life
io io io io sono su life è praticamente
ragazzi un gioco similissimo a proprio
sì ma può quasi one con la stessa cosa
di agar io sono che la cosa che lo rende
diversa la cosa che mi fa piacere di più
e che ci sono i serpenti siccome erano
mai giocato ad haga rio lavoro mai in
anche una volta nella mia vita ea siamo
già a partire la madonna che bello
l'audio è un gioco pieno di emozioni
uditive viene un attimino come funziona
perché ci ho fatto un paio di partite
prima
l'obiettivo è quello di diventare il
serpente più lungo di tutta quanta la
mappa allora ci sono 524 giocatori in
questo momento io devo diventare il
primo cioè quello più lungo di tutti in
questo momento sono di grande ecco
questo è più piccolo di me no cazzo sono
un idiota ma quello che avete appena
visto ecco non si gioca così l'obiettivo
minimo è diventare grosso come questi
solo che il più grosso proprio più
grande carrozzone sta uccidendo un
enorme di più grosso è il primo quindi
l'obiettivo è diventare primo rispetto a
tutti i 500 tipo questo paladini pupa al
pene è praticamente per farlo devo
raccogliere questi cosini che mi fanno
ingrandire e se uccide una persona e con
persona intendo verme di tipo come avete
visto mi da altri pallini che mi fanno
diventare più grande l'obiettivo
arrivare prima per uccidere uno di sea
deficienti o povero pupa devo passargli
davanti così e fotter lì le robe
perfetto avete capito in realtà io sono
fatto stazione strafiga ogni volta che
vado di turbo così
non ci credo mai non ci credo mai cosa
ho fatto
non è vero non è questo che mi foti
punti brutto stronzo e che poi gli altri
no sto cercando la madre è quella del
tizio proprio cioè non a caso questo
sono morto per farvi capire come si
muore perché non me lo ha ancora
spiegato visto qua mi piace tantissimo
rispetto ad haga riceverà mente molto
più figo ragazzi perché io adoro snake
proprio il giochino in sé per sé
lo adoro di così come ha fatto a non
morire ragazzi decreto è che fa questo è
un deficiente che bei ragazzi il bell
amato notte grosso questo no bastardo
già fottuti lega ci ha chiusi dentro e
vabbè come faccio uscire
ragazzi questa è una tattica di
soggiorno per gli eventi ragazzi ci si
attorciglia attorno a un tizio
ovviamente se si è abbastanza grossi per
farlo io sono ancora minuscolo bravo se
piace vincere facile frate bravo
complimenti dopo dicendo prima che
qualche deficiente mi uccidesse la cosa
bella di suo gioco che se sei minuscolo
se sei anche il più piccolo di tutti i
vermiciattoli puoi far fuori il numero
uno quello più grosso cioè tutto sta
nella sua bravura nel non colpire la
coda dall'altro
ovviamente se sei un nano cioè io che
sono un nano è difficile che sto
deficiente qui che è enorme mi colpisca
perché è molto più facile che lo
colpisca io però ragazzi può succedere
non si può mai dire tratto con l'umore 1
grossissimo lascia un miliardo di punti
qualcuno me lo [ __ ] oddio è morto ma
non è morto sta usando tour madonna come
visto fottendo lega c'e neanche
veramente sono un verme provetto il rota
non ho capito ma se cosa che si muovono
danno più punti quanto ti deve morire la
famiglia da 1 a tua nonna
la cosa divertente ragazzi che non mi
avete visto morire quando sono ai
livelli alti o è morto madonna cosa ho
fatto
non ci sono grossissimo non ci sono
gigante e vabbè tutti i punti vi fottono
stile efficienti che voi ragazzi quando
ne muore uno tutti alla che avevo tutti
a cavalcare per i punti da tre color ci
stava bene deficienti lega sono dei
deficienti cosa ci dobbiamo guardare
come si buttano per i punti
il culo ragazzi che se ne muore uno
gigantesco io mi trovo lì in quel
momento va con tanti di quei punti in un
secondo che non avete idea è questo il
bello visto giorgio la volta in cui
arriverò prima in questo gioco ragazzi
la prossima volta lo gioco nudo
seriamente 9 dalla madonna quanto
arrivato incazzato quanti punti
che culo a tutti mi stanno morendo tutti
davanti che purissimo sono più grossi
no dai che di memorie più cugino corda
mi sono salvato è ok ok quanti punti
quanti punti quanti punti quanti punti o
madonna caso ho preso non si che bello
che non ci possa arrivare perchè ce sto
demente davanti bravo brutto deficiente
togliti dai zio che questo piccolo mi
fotte lo so già ragazzi se siete più
grossi non siete più forti ce ne sono
corsi sul tipo etico il fegato e ucciso
un nano nano tipo questo che però non
metterò mai mi conviene stare vicina lo
stavo dicendo lega stavo dicendo mi
conviene stare vicino a quelli grossi
che se muoiono viva i punti che poi
hanno capito se prendendo i punti di
vento grosso quanto loro quanta roba
quanta roba eh va beh ragazzi ho preso
devo levarmi dai [ __ ] che pieno di
gente guarda la porta miniere tutti qua
[ __ ] dai ragazzi toglietevi si
sicuro e morto uno avanti
dovete togliervi se non vi tornò ragazzi
devo levarmi di qua ogni volta che
diventò grosso dove cercare di togliermi
perché se non mi tolgo mi fanno il culo
non ci credo mai dai ragazzi basta
che palle tutti contro di me siete da
passare in mezzo che casino quando
diventi grosso non sei mai con uscirci
ma a questo stronzo come mi segue o cosa
si chiama come me banana banana tour
pian piano giocando a sta roba in parole
tattiche vele spiegate quello che poi da
temi dei consigli voi da teli anche a
lui consigli che fa un po più schifo di
una tattica che ho capito che bisogna
stare vicini a quelli grossi quando si è
piccoli si crepano diventate giganti
numero due è che quando diventate
giganti voi dovete riuscire a staccarvi
dal gruppo perché sono in gruppo hanno
tutti quanti quindi niente
no è vero che non si può andare il sopra
se stesso quando faccio la corsa tipo
questa ecco così quando faccio questa
cosa qui spreco lunghezza c'è nel senso
di vento più piccola quindi è per questo
che tutti non stanno costantemente in
corso perché sono diventano tutti i più
piccoli questo mi muore perché loro che
lo circonda così come stiamo
è ormai rim orto zio che ci doveva dirmi
segue iraq
mi segue l'iraq voleva portarmi voleva
dio è morto uno li oddio è morto un
altro l'atcm le foto di fa forse no ho
visto il frontale malissimo culo
[ __ ]
volevo [ __ ] io dai fan e dai basta
chiamiamoci il rocco ragazzi se mi
chiamo rocco dobbiamo vincere per forza
cioè si sa che rocco e quello che c'ha
al verme più grosso ecco ci siamo
metti girano le parti chi sei grazie
fratelli a trovarsi
[Musica]
sì ho fatto l'ho fatto l'ho fatto l'ho
fatto guarda cosa mi dice che adesso ci
pensi due volte la prossima volta che mi
devi rompere i trequarti di budella
comunqe ragazzi secondo me io ho giocato
veramente poco sì ce l'ha fatta
lo [ __ ] e moris cugino ma perchè vi
conviene stare vicinissimo a quelli
grotte sì sì sì sì sì sì sì sì ma avrà
tratto l'ho ucciso io mi sa credo di
averlo ucciso io grandissimo la tattica
ragazzi la tattica di stare vicino a
quelli grossi funziona la dio ma giuro
che è bravo prenditela con quel comune
dato a taglia ma che l'amato chi è
questo qui quanto grosso questo quanto
beh ragazzi fate finta no perché sono
molto ios e se abbiamo fatto un frontale
in faccia perché sono morto io termiche
ho trovato il nuovo kit mario ci ho
messo una vita e mezzo a trovarlo poi ho
trovato quando trovi uno grosso sembra
di essere entrati in autostrada che era
fantastico chimiche crepe in quel che vi
supplico iddio qualcuno lo faccia fuori
vipre che lou reed of figlio della
ragazzi se prova a resistere il più
possibile che probabilità di vincere se
prova a resistere
oddio oddio cosa sta succedendo
cosa sta succedendo conferme come è
successo a sta cosa come e morto che
introvabili t'avevo di salvarmi nessuno
ero morto grandissimo zio tre ragazzi
basta per oggi basta veramente non è una
roba insostenibile sto gioco che
ringrazio per anni consigliato il gioco
che si è rivelato essere molto
tranquillo poco dopo bisogno grazie sto
sbagliando qualcosa di te me no e se
avete qualche consiglio in più fatemelo
sapere nei commenti ragazzi nel prossimo
episodio cercherò di migliorare o
comunque ci provo quindi ragazzi se il
video è piaciuto massa intestato un
commento è un mi piace è che a pagina di
facebook che ogni video trascrizione
senso che si discute i civili devono
prossimo vito bel ragazzo